oh no I'm just trying to help
[Music]
hi guys it's Alex so today I'm gonna be
making a giant rain job cake it's really
cool it's this clear looking cake
although I don't really know why they
call it a cake because it looks more
like jello we've actually made a couple
on our page
tasty Japan because raindrop cake was
invented in Japan it's usually served
with a roasted soybean flour and black
serum I've never been made a
regular-sized raindrop cake before but
there's only a couple of ingredients
socks should go into it so I feel like
it can make a giant one okay this is too
watery this pink cake I don't know like
I don't know this cake alright let's
make it rain so before I even try it to
make a giant raindrop cake I feel like I
should start small make a regular-sized
raindrop cake let's see what happens so
range of cake really only takes three
main ingredients water sugar and this
thing called agar agar it's actually
made from algae or seek help you can buy
agar agar in most like health food
stores you can order it on Amazon or go
to like any Asian market so it's not
that hard to find you need to bring that
to a boil on high heat now that we're
out of oil I'm gonna reduce the heat to
low and we're gonna cook that for two
more minutes two minutes two minutes we
gotta wait for two minutes this may be
the easiest one we've done yet although
we haven't really done anything yet so
maybe efficient is taking anything I'm
already like a little tiny bit concerned
just because I feel like this isn't
completely clear it's a little more
opaque and that will be a problem
where's our ice
need to get this out of here so now we
put the pan in the ice bath and we're
gonna leave it in there for three
minutes
whoa it's thick this doesn't seem right
where's ba ba tell me what you're doing
and tell me what you are going to do if
I knew why would I ask you over so it
has to be a problem with the agar
because there's only three ingredients
in this is sugar water and oh my god I
did see that there were two kinds so
there's powder and flakes yeah I could
only find the flakes that's what I buy I
think if I need to use powder say
walking front okay so here is my
experiment I'm going to try to grind up
this agar into a powder from the flakes
version there's still flakes I mean we
gotta go get the powder
okay so we're taking a little field trip
to the Japanese market to go find some
agar powder because the flakes just
aren't cutting it I don't know where I'm
going so they were at a stalk tastes a
lot of people are making raindrop cakes
today I'm gonna try to go to a different
Japanese market okay we finally have the
agar agar powder it took me three stores
to find this so I really hope that it
works I'm ready for some rain it's been
a try so this time I'm also gonna use
bottled spring water the tap water kind
of taste it too metallic and also this
should give us pure raindrop I'm just
gonna do two tablespoons of the agar
powder we have and hopefully it works
this time I'm just gonna pour it into
this bowl and put it in the fridge to
cool it looks clearer than last time but
I'm curious to see what it looks like
once it's set Oh
oh that's weird
I do much prefer the taste of it with
the bottled spring water than the tap
water
consistency I'm gonna give myself about
an eighth clarity three high stay - I
feel like I've identified a few of the
factors that have been going wrong so
I'm gonna try to remedy those today I'm
going to blend up the sugar to make it
more of like a baker's fine sugar which
will make it easier to dissolve in the
hot water
they still agar agar in a few forms I've
learned I'm gonna use a pure powder with
nothing added to it this is gonna make
it much easier to measure out properly
and it should also dissolve easier into
water I used two tablespoons of agar
agar last time and how it was way too
much like you only need an eighth of a
teaspoon per cup of water I don't know
how how I was so off but yeah so I'm
gonna let that come to a simmer and then
I'm gonna add in our fine Baker sugar I
guess technically every raindrop cake is
a giant rainbow cake because raindrops
are tiny I feel confident about this one
it looks really clear just gonna pour
this in here Oh pull in a little bit
we're gonna put this in the fridge just
so I don't waste an hour of my day I'm
actually gonna just make another one and
change up the ratio just to see my back
that's so instead of an eighth of a
teaspoon I'm gonna try to use 1/4 of a
teaspoon
well so this is the fourth of a teaspoon
about our agar definitely clear than
yesterday still not completely
transparent but it's not quite to set
station of like a raindrop bursting this
one doesn't work then I'm going to be
crying my own raindrops from my eyes
okay
as crazy as it sounds I do think we're
closer I need to fall somewhere in
between these two hopefully fourth time
is the charm this time I'm going to do
the same exact method but just with a
quarter-teaspoon about our a guard and
one and a half cups water hopefully this
is the sweet spot one hour
okay it's just got really stuck on to
the bottom of the bowl yeah I feel like
it's rain dropping I just got to figure
out how to keep it in a raindrop shape
should I just try to do the giant one
sometimes in life you just gotta go for
things also I just want to be done with
it
so I bought this metal cake bowl because
it has no line at the bottom I felt it
would be like the perfect mold
I'm already anticipating then I'm gonna
have to tweak the amount of agar to
water for the giant one just because
it's gonna need to be a little bit
stronger to hold its shape so now I just
have to figure out how much water this
actually is so I'm gonna pour it back
into our measuring cup okay so let's
just make this an even 8 cups
8 cups divided by 1 and 1/4 cups is
[Music]
everybody so I'm doing two teaspoons of
our agar agar and 4 teaspoons of our
fine Baker's sugar so because this bowl
doesn't have a bottom edge I'm putting
it in this bowl to stabilize it when I
pour in the mixture should I put in the
flour or two we're gonna make a little
bouquet at the bottom Wow I wonder if
this is gonna work that would be amazing
yeah they're just so the flowers not
only don't fit bottom they've colored my
raindrop to a weird swamp green I don't
know about this hopefully I did my math
probably didn't
it literally died the bowl since day
three
hopefully third time is the charm so
this was D giant bowl we used I went out
and got two smaller sizes because I feel
as though this was just a little too big
and also it's still technically a giant
raindrop cake so I'm not cheating I've
realized we really need to compensate
for it leap giant size of this and it
will just take a little more AG art than
a normal sized straight drop cake way so
I guess we'll just start boiling you
know the drill so I tried to dissolve
this as much as possible but I'm still
gonna strain it just as an added measure
of precaution to make sure we don't have
any floaters in our raindrop it is set
it's probably a little too sets not
flipping oh I'm so over this 3/8 did
tell me to do some trick fat like works
with unmolding and that is to spin
that's not worked yeah
you've lied to me I'm really dizzy
alright it's day 4 I specifically wore
this shirt because I'm desperately
trying to keep my cool vibes so last
night I decided to make three test
patches each with different ratios I
also decided to use
bowls because the other ones just
weren't coming out I guess now it's time
to flip them all and see which one if
any of them work gotta put my thing down
flip it and reverse it it's your flow in
it
they're starting with this one 1
tablespoon of agar agar powder with 8
cups of water and 1 tablespoon of sugar
oh okay
nothing is really satisfying actually
just the kind of fell out of the bowl
it's super delicate but it's holding its
shape which is really good these both
have less agar to water and I'm still
gonna flip them but I'm pretty positive
that they are going to fall apart okay
oh yeah I just really wanted to see what
would happen
honestly I'm pretty happy I think we
still have one that's promising if we up
this ratio just a little bit we'll have
our rainbow cake gonna clean this up a
little bit okay this is it this is it I
hope this is it cuz I don't want to do
this again it's important to actually
dissolve your agar powder in cold water
first which is something I wish I knew
before
now we're gonna be dissolving our agar
in cold water with the sugar and then
we're going to transfer it to heat and
bring that to a simmer not for too long
just a couple of minutes if you boil it
or leave it on the heat for too long it
will deactivate the agent bring it to a
simmer we're gonna get a simmer okay
stop 2 minutes taking this off the heat
whoom I wish I made a different noise
than that but I couldn't think of
anything that was a better noise
oh I'm going to very carefully try to
get this to the fridge why did we do
this so far from the fridge this is like
the opposite of track and field
wow that was honestly the hardest part
of this whole thing actually is this say
five how did we get here
so I've left my raindrop cake chill
overnight before I even flip it which I
am terrified to do I'm gonna make my
brown sugar syrup so all it takes is two
cups of brown sugar and one cup of water
we're doing a lot of dissolving this
process all it is is dissolving now I'm
just gonna let it cool down and it will
thicken up which is the beauty of a
syrup okay we've made it it is time to
flip this thing I am really really
really really really really really
nervous I should have gone pee before
just it literally looks like just you
know go for it
[Music]
oh my god I did it okay here we go
whoo oh my god I'm shaking okay we've
got some rain I'm gonna put this soybean
flour around the edge I'm super good
it's like rustic I did it I have to say
the toppings really do make this you get
the sweetness from the syrup we made and
then the roasted soybean flour kind of
gives it a nuttiness and it's also super
refreshing so a great summer dessert wet
[Music]